على خط ستار لينك كثير شركه ميتا الملكه
لتطبيق واتساب لم يعد التواصل بين
المحتجين عبر التطبيق الاشهر في العالم
هما في ايران حتى وان كان يشكل صداعا في
راس القائمين على الاجهزه الامنيه
فمع بدايه العام الجاري اعلن تطبيق واتساب
على تويتر اليه الدخول اليه في البلدان
التي يعاني سكانها من قمع وقيود على
الانترنت
نواصل النظام من اجل حقك في التواصل بحريه
وسريه عندما يتعذر الاتصال بواتساب مباشره
يمكنك البقاء على اتصال من خلال خادم تم
اعداده بواسطه متطوعين ومؤسسات مكرسات
لمساعده الاخرين
وفقا لصحيفه واشنطن بوست اعلن واتساب بشكل
منفصل عن اطلاق ميزته الجديده باللغه
الفارسيه كما شرح عمليا كيفيه الوصول
للتطبيق عبر تعديل اعداداته للوصول الى
الانترنت من خلال خوادم بروكسي التي تعمل
كوسيط بين المستخدمين ومقدم خدمات
الانترنت ويعد تطبيق واتساب الاكثر شعبيه
في العالم بعد وصول مستخدمه لاكثر من
مليارين مستخدم في 180 دوله واتساب لم يكن
التطبيق الاول الذي تورت السلطات
الايرانيه الى حجبه في مواجهه الاحتجاجات
فسبقه انستغرام وفيسبوك وتويتر وتلجرام
تسويق لتطبيقات بديله للمراسله من قبل
الحكومه الايرانيه
لكنها لم تسلم من التعرض لهجوم سيبراني
وفقا لشركه البنيه التحتيه للاتصالات
السلكيه واللاسلكيه ليظل الوصول الى خدمه
الانترنت والتطبيقات التواصل الاجتماعي
عائقا امام السلطات الايرانيه في مسحها
لقمع الاحتجاجات المتواصله منذ ثلاثه اشهر
علي السمان العربيه